this morning in our Saturday session
Craig fan these perhaps best known as
the frontman for the Hold Steady and for
writing rich evocative songs in which
characters emerge and stories unfold
he's also built a solo career and just
last week he released his fourth solo
collection he'll perform here in studio
57 in just a moment but first I had a
chance to sit down with Craig Fenn here
in New York
[Music]
small Craig fan writes about characters
just trying to find their footing in
this crazy world I think of you as a
storyteller almost more than a
songwriter yeah do you feel that way I
feel both I've always thought I should
write a book or I should write a short
story or something but every time I get
an idea it turns into a song
[Music]
I got nothing
tomorrow maybe I can see you tonight
[Music]
lose ourselves
they feel cinematic do you see pictures
in your head I see pictures when I write
the stories and I sort of try to follow
him into that world raised in
Minneapolis Finn started writing songs
in junior high after college he decided
he wanted to be the frontman in a band
was the driving force that you wanted to
sing your own songs yeah yeah I mean I
wanted and I was starting to write and
hear it in a way that I knew I could I
can deliver these songs in their way
[Music]
there's a rhythm to them absolutely
that's totally yours it's a very
percussive thing I almost never hold the
note but it's all you know one syllable
two one one
[Music]
boys and girls in America
he was 31 when he formed the hold steady
the ban broke through with their second
album separation Sunday
[Music]
we're on the cover the Village Voice
well that was a big thing back then you
think another big moment for the band
when their song the bear and the maiden
fair was featured on Game of Thrones
how did you get that then the guys who
created it we're big fans I will say it
it put me in touch with how big game of
thrones this
is that gonna happen your phone just
sort of levitates off yeah but even more
important for Finn was when the whole
steady played at a Bruce Springsteen
tribute at New York's Carnegie Hall and
Bruce asked Finn to take the lead
singing Rosalita I now have a dog named
Rosalita because because I got to sing
Rosalita with Bruce that night Finn
still fronts the whole steady but he
says his solo work has made him more
sympathetic with the struggling
characters of his songs they're doing
their best and they're trying to do the
right thing and they're still having
difficulty keeping their head above
water and I think that's you know 2019
really interesting to me